One surprising aspect of "Wednesday" has some
fans flocking to social media to fawn over star
Jenna Ortega. It isn't her deadpan demeanor or the
character's sadistic impulses. It's pure talent.
Since cartoonist Charles Addams introduced his
"Addams Family" cartoons in the late 1930s,
the beloved oddball family has been adapted
into live action on several occasions.
First came the 1964 television series,
which ran for 64 episodes over two
seasons. Despite its short run, the series
did an excellent job of bringing the Addams
clan into mainstream pop culture, and the
original cast returned for a 1977 TV movie.
Director Barry Sonnenfeld built upon this
groundwork in 1991 with his feature film,
"The Addams Family," which was followed by a 1993,
sequel, "Addams Family Values." For many fans,
the undeniable standout of both features was
Christina Ricci's take on Wednesday Addams.
Gomez and Morticia's stoic, twisted
daughter became a hit with moviegoers,
making Wednesday one of the most
popular members of the family.
"I'm not perky."
It's a natural progression, then, to Netflix's
"Wednesday," a show all about the character
coming of age and solving a deadly mystery that
has plagued her family for years. "Wednesday"
premiered on Netflix on November 23, 2022,
introducing subscribers to Jenna Ortega's
version of the beloved character. For
the most part, audiences seem impressed
with what she has to offer as Wednesday, with
one aspect in particular really wowing them.
Not long after "Wednesday" arrived on
Netflix, fans flocked to social media
to express their adoration for Jenna Ortega's
cello performances on the show. One tweeted,
Another commented,
Fans' love of the cello scenes inevitably led to
questions about where to find more. One asked,
Another fan tweeted that they loved the symbolism
behind one of Wednesday's cello performances:
Though some fans took to social media to
praise the show's soundtrack as a whole,
many tweeted requests for more scenes of Ortega
showing off her musical talent. One wrote:
As if her performances on the show weren't
impressive enough, it turns out that Ortega
had no cello experience going into the
Netflix series. In an interview with Wired,
Ortega revealed that she learned to play the cello
specifically for "Wednesday." She hasn't picked
the instrument up much since filming wrapped
because she's been busy with other projects,
but it's clearly something she has a
great appreciation for in hindsight.
"I have immense respect for anybody who plays the
cello. I think it's such a delightful instrument."
Fans once again hurled praise at Ortega when they
found out the "Wednesday" star had no prior
experience with the instrument. One wrote,
Another tweeted,
Another Twitter user praised the
"Wednesday" creative team for
making the scenes as musically
authentic as possible, saying,
That same tweeter hypothesized that a professional
must have played during the close-up shots.